this happened bro a couple of italians
threw a flat screen off a damn uh thing
yo we're on the 47th the floor here
oh my god and none of you can see this
literally
it's two two white dudes one of them in
a straight up
gida jersey okay so
uh italian could be jewish this kid but
it looks italian
um but definitely has a television
obviously it's either it's probably from
the hotel 42nd floor these two dudes are
yacked up baby
on some of that italian yak baby that
giddy up bro
that freaking brain father dog you know
what i'm talking about baby
that freaking genealogy dust baby you
snort your way back to your grandfather
on some of that strong
[ __ ] baby gang and they just threw a
television off the 42nd floor
in what looks like i'm gonna say this is
las vegas
[Music]
i love how as soon as it hits the guy
runs into the hotel room
like at that like at that point
oh man that [ __ ] is good dude oh that
was good
so right there that's full italian man
and that is
uh i mean it says you know what makes me
mad
the quality of product
and that's product quality they call it
but that makes me mad man a long time
ago dude television you threw that [ __ ]
off you needed two people to throw that
[ __ ]
okay and when that thing hit dude
i mean timothy mcveigh probably you know
his spine got a little straighter
you know that thing really those things
it was
glass on the front and it was a damn
there was a bulb in there and there was
some real weight and girth to it that
thing
that thing would get to the 42 floors in
five seconds this thing took five to
eight seconds
it should that thing landed like a damn
dove down there
that thing landed like a dove baby damn
so we need to just heavy these [ __ ]
up man
but that's a ballsy move man
throwing that thing 42 floors throwing a
tv
off man praise god that's italian daddy
let's go
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one